welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's latest eternals
trailer began to give us some answers
about the big picture of the mcu and how
we've apparently been praying to the
wrong people show me what you got
heavenly heads and cranial creator
forgive my transgressions against family
and community made my chores complete me
as i complete them but it is these
celestials and eternals link to thanos
that has us most curious the mad titan
was brought up twice in the trailer
first by ajac when talking about him
snapping away half of all life five
years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe and then
later in a chat between dane whitman and
cersei why didn't you guys help fight
thanos or any war all the other terrible
things throughout history we were
instructed not to interfere in any human
conflicts unless deviants are involved
yeah but [ __ ] you may be thinking
and politely because thanos while born
to eternal parents carried a deviant
gene the source of his scarred purple
skin shouldn't that have qualified him
as deviant enough for the eternals to
intervene well the answer isn't entirely
clear because when you go back and look
at how the mcu has defined thanos
backstory and lineage the studio has
been very careful with what clues
exactly they've offered so far as to
thanos's exact bloodline i suspect that
only will this film answer that question
but that answer could provide the basis
for how things like the mutant gene
could be established in this universe
thanos's parents were eternals alars aka
mentor and sui-san living on titan now
in the comics titan is the moon of
saturn titan but in the films titan is a
planet outside of our solar system and
we know the movies intend to keep thanos
lineage intact because when red skull
greeted thanos on vermeer he'd mentioned
his father's name as a way to prove his
divine insight
now alards moved to titan from earth
after a dispute with his brother the
eternal zurus who is the father of fina
making theena and thanos first cousins
and if you're a president with a school
and loki named after you not a deal
breaker but while thanos's eternals
bloodline has been confirmed for the
films his deviance has not yet been
explicitly mentioned the closest
evidence we've gotten was thanos's
explanation to doctor strange infinity
war titan was like most planets
too many mouths not enough to go around
and when we faced extinction i offered a
solution
genocide
but random just passionate fair to rich
and poor alike
they called me a madman yeah there
thanos is a reality stone conjured
projection of titan's past shows what
looks like a peaceful society of titans
though from what i can determine none of
them appear to be purple scarred and
jacked the implication seems like the
titan skepticism of thanos might have
had some racial bias to it now in the
comics that prejudice led thanos's own
mother sui-sun to attempt to murder him
at birth considering him a deviant who
would go on to destroy civilization but
really in that moment deviant is thrown
as a kind of slur describing thanos's
phenotype thanos has long been
considered an eternal hyphen deviant or
an eternal with a deviant gene sometimes
called an eternal deviant hybrid though
he's not half and half actually if we're
going to be specific he's really a
pureborn eternal with a deviant genetic
mutation a dormant gene buried in his
dna that he got from his ancestors that
was only now activated the moment of his
conception and if that science is how
this eternal film describes thanos
genetic history we're in for a very
different conversation in this film when
it comes to subjects like mutants in the
mcu but this video is brought to you by
the ridge the ridge wallet is light
sleek and industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky monstrosities that make us sit
crooked when they're in our back pockets
the ridge comes in over 30 styles and
colors including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash so you can show
off your fancy euro collection to
cashiers and other people who probably
don't care every ridge wallet comes with
a lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it they also have great backpacks phone
cases and other cool gear they're
running a special promotion where every
dollar spent on the site before
september 18th you're entered to win a
2020 jeep gladiator or 50 000 bucks if
you already own a cool convertible jeep
or if you just prefer cash so get 10 off
today with free worldwide shipping and
returns by going to ridge.com new
rockstars that's ridge.com new rockstars
and use code new rockstars find the link
in the video's description the eternals
comics established that the celestials
created three groups of intelligent life
on earth the eternals the humans and the
deviants but within humankind they
encoded a latent gene that would not
activate for untold millennia implied to
be the mutant gene or x gene as mutants
began to emerge among the population as
far back as insaba nur of ancient egypt
aka the mutant apocalypse mankind didn't
really realize this was happening they
didn't yet have a word for them until
the modern era mutants are really
considered a random genetic variation to
humans but still part of that same
species so too may have been the case
with thanos born an eternal considered
an eternal just merely possessing a
deviant mutation but still from the
perspective of the celestials and from
thanos's cousin dina maybe an eternal
same as arrested them creating among the
eternals a kind of confusion whether or
not to act it's even possible that
thanos's war path was celestial inspired
and ordered the writers of infinity war
talked about structuring thanos's
journey as a spiritual quest giving him
dogmatic dialogue in a final shot with
biblical undertones and we know there is
some historical link between the
celestials and the infinity stones one
of the first celestials we saw in the
mcu was issan the searcher in the
collector's story who once possessed the
power stone and the nebula in endgame
described vormir the resting place of
the soul stone as a dominion of death at
the very center of celestial existence
and there is some untold story of how
thanos acquired his first infinity stone
the mind stone because loki was given
the scepter by thanos's minion the other
in order to conquer earth and acquire
the tesseract the space stone but that
scepter was later revealed to contain
the mind stone meaning thanos must have
somehow gotten that stone first and
perhaps it was a gift from the gods
because it just seems like the
celestials wanted thanos to carry out
that cosmic genocide based on ajax's
words in the eternals trailer but the
people of this planet brought everyone
back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin now i've
talked about how that emergence could
refer to a lot of things like the
emergence of the deviants the emergence
of mutants on earth the emergence of a
sleeping celestial gestating inside
earth like an egg the emergence of
people unsubscribing when my theories
reach too far hey come back come back
but in any of these cases i think the
celestials have begun this process
because mankind like icarus mythological
analog flew too close to the sun the
avengers defied the celestial's will
that was carried out by the celestial's
chosen son thanos and if you think about
it thanos's status as a celestial's
champion could be the explanation to his
unique genetic condition because if his
deviant gene is described as a mutation
similar preconditions are being
increasingly encoded into several mcu
characters like wanda maximoff was
capable of casting low-level probability
hexes as a young girl years before
infinity stone radiation which we
believe could be marvel's way of saying
we know wanda maximoff was a mutant in
the marvel comics and we are now saying
she was born this way also the black
widow movie established ursa major a
russian mutant at now mcu cannon and
thanos now as a possible herald of the
celestials could be to future mcu
generations a harbinger of mutants
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options including our new
marvel what if inspired limited edition
shirt and new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you